bonjour bonjour et bienvenue à tous
championnat de france agen 2016 donc on
est aujourd'hui
et bien après la revente de quatre
enfants courent de gros de 4ème et je
suis avec le maître international jean
françois joly bonjour jean françois
bonjour sérieux alors tu fais un battu
fait un très bon tournoi et aujourd'hui
tu as réussi à une victoire je dirais
d'importance parce que tu as battu le
leader c'est moi c'est inespéré déjà de
faire de participer au tournoi ses
supérieurs et bien je me fais plaisir
alors à noter que tu es qualifier pour
ce tournoi pour avoir l'an dernier finit
deuxième de l'accession est tout à fait
c'était déjà une belle performance mais
son lob était vraiment difficile
j'étais vraiment hyper toi tant la
dernière de gagner ma place
ouais je crois c'est déjà une super
performance quand on voit la cession par
le même cette année on nageait jean-marc
dogra qui fait l'accession je crois
qu'il sait mais c'est encore plus fort
je pense que c'est encore plus fort
qu'elle dernière mais bon la dernière
déjà c'était c'est déjà bien relevé et a
enlevé lé adrien demuth qui est devenu
très pâle veltins jean-luc shabelle
pienaar bouge avec jade un han et tout
ce qu'ils oublient ouais ouais donc
c'était déjà une super terre et j'avais
joué et vous n'allez fait qu'on annule
les faits il était à 7 sur 7 et j'avais
un point et demi de retard qui
commençait à gérer un peu le tour
d'accord et donc ça tu as hâte a permis
de marquer un point un demi point
précieux à ce moment là sans doute oui
oui c'est alors cette année tu fais un
super nationale parce que bon tu as
quand même perdu une partie mais tu as
marqué deux fois et la ccsa justice
espérait 2 et puis par pape pas face à
n'importe qui et a battu donc c'est
vraiment c'est ça le
roman j'ai perdu contre lui et a permis
aux romains et les comptes christian à
leurs homologues a battu le champion de
l'an dernier et le leader et qui
d'ailleurs un dernier était troisième en
plus a donc fait rigoler tout à fait au
début 4e mn je crois parce que trop même
si bak rouge premier donc voilà donc
super super tournant pour jean-françois
donc on va regarder ta partira peut-être
évidemment venir sur le coup numéro un
ce sera mieux parce que j'en ai un peu
sur la fin
voilà donc alors tu as les blancs dans
cette partie voilà chez les blancs je
joue ça sert mathieu corne est un
spécialiste de l'italienne puisque will
la joie hier contre adrian newey
ce qui est étonnant c'est que tu vas
quand même rentrer dans une italienne
ouais en fait je habituellement je
voulais steiner quasi-exclusivement est
bon comme lui il est pas il est pas
joueur de 4,5
il joue plus la sicile où la france est
tout comme ça d'accord comme il a joué à
quatre ça je me suis dit qu'il va être
préparé un truc sur l'espagnol
donc j'ai changé et tiens jouit sa
variante qu'il joue avec les blancs
après je sais qu'ils jouent plein de
trucs avec les bleus il aussi décapant
anglaise du fonds il peut tout faire
donc ouais mais sachant qu'ils avaient
gagnés dont une italienne
c est ça que j'avais pas forcément fait
le fait le rapprochement avec sa partie
d'hier mais voilà comme souvent
l'italienne il ya des similarités que
l'espagnol du coup j'ai du tennis a fait
pas je n'ai pas trop perdu
voilà c'est vrai c'est vrai que souvent
les plans ressemble
dans il ya des transpositions qui arrive
dakoro on y va on va regarder cette
partie donc quatre scènes dont je veux
la paix dont peu surpris déjà puisque
wyeth attendaient à ces cinq ou six
c'est ça ouais voilà c'était plus que
j'avais révisé ce matin et l'aval a pour
première surprise over d'accord de la
cavaille le 3 qu'avec ses six fosses et
cabella tu te dis il a sans doute
préparé un truc contre mon espagnol
voilà ce que je j'ai déjà quelques
parties je pense ou c'est assez facile
de se préparer donc j'ai décidé de
changer donc vous et 4 aulas donc voilà
on en connaît les arcanes de la
préparation de jean-françois ça se fait
sur l'échiquier il celui que le gars a
préparé un truc europe
il lui fait un point commun l'acro la
même faut alors cavalli et 6 donc tu
attaques le pion aux quatre alors déjà
alors tweak aller alors là tu peux jouer
on peut jouer le fameux coup qu'alléger
sac à langer ça c'est aussi une
possibilité mais bon qu'est qui est
super compliqué donc tu fais des
endroits là je voulais jouer en italien
avec des trois sets rouge les trucs de
10 ont transposé dans les espèces
exactement pour rester à peu près d'un
teint d'intérêt que tu connais moi la
zone de confort que là c'est normal
petit robe qui ronge petit rôle et je ne
sais pas s'il ya un joueur comme
mathieu avec les noirs qui a l'habitude
qui viennent de gagner une partie la
ronde précédente avec les blancs sur une
italienne qui en plus ressembler un
présent il doit être mal à l'aise parce
que finalement il se dit avec les blancs
c'est fort il a les noirs de plus bien
sa partie du centre de la partie d'hier
adrian est sorti fond c'est ça qui nous
avait caché sa voix la voix si ces x 7
ouais c'est ça mais c'est vrai que j'ai
perdu tout j'ai pas du tout fait le
rapprochement que la partie d'hier en
fait d'accord voiture et c'était
vraiment voilà l'histoire de faire une
partie on est sûr centre ou de
préparation à tous les deux puis voilà
jouer et surtout tu te sentais en forme
pas de pas de stress particulier
attention je vais rien à faire j'avais
déjà marqué un point e
c'était déjà bien c'est de vries est
déjà là n'est pas beaucoup qui marquait
un point et demi d'arrêt national pareil
tu aurais donc tranquille ça c'est
normal des six essais 3 alors dans
l'espagne part souvent on joue ça
d'ailleurs le foot en bessin y avait un
tas d'or bien ces deux et puis alors par
contre on attend pour jouer avant de
jouer d'éclat d'avoir joué le coup à je
crois ou ai souvent parce que sinon le
plus fou g4 pour les voleurs veut mettre
de la pression sur le sur le central à
blanc parce que sa pelouse le cavalier
qui contrôle les classes centrale donc
si avant de jouer des quatre on joue à
trois sinon si les noirs jouent
eux-mêmes fou j'étais trop tôt on sur le
carillon de d2f un g3 ça et puis on le
chasse ensuite parce qu'il peut parvenir
à 11,5 du cavalier donc la période
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que j'ai joué
ses trois plutôt qu'un coup que
lecavalier bd 2 way pour anticiper un
coup comme cavalier à 5 qui prendrait
m'en fout en fait ouais alors là il peut
plus il peut le faire là il peut faire
cavalier à 5
au regard des lots dans ce cas là bas je
vais me faufiler je vais faire fouille
des sacs
voilà voilà sa valise et l'espagnol en
fait ainsi soit 4 à 6 soit cadets 5 et
ou s'il me fous pas quelque chose ces
deux voies là et on devrait en aidant
une espagnole ouais c'est de transposer
l'inspection eh bien peut-être là du
coup c'était parce qu'il avait préparée
contre toi il ya peut-être préparer un
gambit marshall ou un truc comme ça je
ne sais pas c
le dire à la prochaine fois west sussex
donc alors roi ouais je suis donc là ses
premiers coups on va dire peut-être
inhabituel dans une autre position je
m'attendais plutôt à ces curieux je
m'attendais plutôt fou si ça doit être
normal pour elle en dira beaucoup
d'attentes
alors j'étais ce qu'ils préparent soit
l'idée de base c'est si je joue
normalement on va dire s'ils jouent
calais b d2 on va être quelque ou à peu
près logis qui va jouer probablement
cavaler g8
carlier en g8 pour envoyer 100 km en
moyenne 1 il ya le faut et à la tour
comme le roi s'est mis ensuite il peut
préparer tout ça déjà une bonne tête
pour les moeurs d'accord donc toi tu
vois ça et donc tu joues ton oui le
jouage 3 ça ce que tu tu te dis si jouer
tellement je vais jouer des quatre parce
que l'action centre c'est ça la clé des
principes les grands principes
d'ouverture et h3 ce sera utile de plein
de variole je veux empêcher flou g4
comme si ça s'ouvre à la hausse
j'ai gravi cgc hall ça paraît logique si
on trouve souvent utiles même d'un
espagnol en joue d'ailleurs et la fois
italie 17 qui avaient des sabots glas
qui avaient des g8 devait pas lui plaire
en fait être un peu passif ou est
peut-être natation il avait déjà prévu
de ramener le caillou investissent pour
attaquer le fou bon mais ça te gêne pas
si tu voues des quatre d'ailleurs parce
que tu peux leur dire la fin
tranquillement au moins deux des trois
ans des trois dont club des 4 ça paraît
logique maintenant le recul de pièces
donc là ça tu traînes plus créative et 6
puis sur le football voilà peut revenir
on a une belle tension tranquille si
j'étais content des joueurs espagnols
reste quoi voilà j'étais content on a
déjà pris un petit peu de temps tous les
deux pas loin d'une demi heure donc
rester la partie tranquille gt c'est
quoi ton donc là il prend les lettres
mettant des pages web parce qu'ils
lâchent un peu le centre en faisant ça
quand même parce que sinon la ici ça
tient bien ses solides un essaim si tu
prends des eaux peut me du lion
peut-être qui peut-être qui peut jouer
cavalier b6 tout de suite je sais pas là
je sais pas trop peut-être un peu faible
secours effectivement parce que ça c'est
un abandon du centre du sens peut-être
après je ne m'étais absenté à une classe
naturelle de développement ce qui l'a
pas au départ et puis tu contrôles
devraient s'y est même pas prévoit la
salle des trucs que j'ai pas à capter un
mois j'ai quand même plutôt content on
va dire ouais donc là maintenant qu'elle
est baissier mais s'ils s'attaquent le
fou donc où elle vivait 3g j'aurais pu
dans les rangs des trois mais j'accorde
cabale des bécasses oui ici tu viens
d'où il peut attaquer là le fou tu peux
paroles aient été obligés de repartir
bon mais après tu peut chasser le
cavalier par rapport à des quatre aussi
peut-être
voilà j'étais entraîneur dsk après fou
détroit qui avait l'éclat des ce que
cavani est mal passé je fais fouet fin
mai mais je savais pas donc ça me
paraissait logique de garder pression
sur les recettes aussi que je fais tous
mettront oui c'est une bonne diagonale
c'est une grenade kiki bombay qui
empêche le droit d'avoir de l'air parce
que dès qu'ils jouent f5 il peut plus
bouger après ça paraissait logique de
venir là et c'est vrai que l'info
espagnol voilà on retrouve donc la d5
voilà il réagit au centre préparait le
logis booba j'ai plusieurs choix et donc
qu'est ce que tu veux je prends le
développement jeu ça jusqu'à ses trois
ans la même date unis aux syndicats en
priant prince a pas l'air bon puisque
c'est à centraliser réfléchit aussi à
fait propre aux cavaliers pros et là je
fais que laissait trop regardé par
exemple c'est un peu dans le même esprit
et maintenant car ici moyens qu'il
oubliait je préférais développer la
position adoptée isolé avec nos
cavaliers ans le 4 et son cavalier en b
6 ça fait c'est dans la partie
c'était comme ça c'est ouais d'accord
donc tu préfère donc sortir le cavalier
moi je sous peu peut-être et il prend
1,4 donc ils te laissent avec le tueur
isolé mais ça ne fait pas peur
là ça me fait pas parce que mes pièces
sont déjà très active d'accord et oui la
courageuse 8 qui peut être un peu
embêtant parce qu'elle s'était moins
bien défendus ça peut lui poser des
problèmes dans certains cas ce qu'on
s'était dit dans le direct de secouer
finalement il s'appelle va du coup c'est
voilà c'est ça fait un petit moment ça a
été joué c'était quand même intéressant
et d'appétit mis en valeur après
peut-être donc tu prends du cavalier et
donc ta confiant alors toujours pareil
quand on accuse au lit il faut jouer
l'activité à la 10ème position dynamique
bosser parce que c'est plus ce qui me
plaît en plus voilà je t'écoute
donc tu étais à théding était dans son
élément enfin voila tu penses avoir
réussi ton début tout est là bas là je
pense que j'ai davantage notre audace
que mes pièces sont vraiment active je
vois pas trop non pas tant ce qu'ils
peuvent faire
bon après c'est pas grand chose alors
fou et 5 est maintenant hop d'atypique
des purs isolé d'ailleurs des points
centraux comme ça on a les deux cases
eux s'inquiètent cependant de travailler
et c'est souvent pénibles d'ailleurs
tout de suite tu as ta douala j'attaque
l'option b 7 et est donc le cav a laissé
six bougies murray je vais faire cavaler
aux 5 oui voilà notre cavallini arriver
là c'est le rêve et passion et c'est
vraiment le pion isolé magnifique et
j'attaquerai vii datacap cette attaque
bessette aura noté aussi que s'ils
bougent pas à tout moment quand tu
prendras ce qu'ils ont mais aussi on le
protège ce call it en l'air voilà ça ça
peut mettre un terme ce sera c'est un
thème intéressant aussi way d'ailleurs
je crois que ça va être vu dans la
partie c'est plus le tour des huit bon
très bien voilà les français donc on
note que en cas de prise cela il n'est
pas défendu donc il suffire il y avait
une autre décision intéressant voilà ce
qui peut faire [ __ ] ans et 5e ce qu'on
peut regarder
ouais mais il donne à l'arrivée même pas
deux fois c'est un faux procès simple et
plus et 5 et toitures et unités puis on
la devine une option c'est vraiment la
vente hd blu ouais parce qu'en plus
c'est facile à défendre cela tu as joué
trois sans doute après tour s'il ya
toujours la pression désagréable
surprise cette qui empêche les sourds de
bouger il va devoir perdre un temps
à protéger les pions pouvoir jouer la 3f
8 soif ou g6 qui est passif quand même
soit ça voilà cette décision-là et
éclaireurs numérotage la paire de foot
dans un jeu complètement ouvert tout à
fait donc voilà il est logique qu'il
déjouait tomber vite du coude pour des
formes et puis on défend 17 et là faut
être quatre très bons coups parce
qu'effectivement bon mais le fou sort
sur une de ses meilleures classes parce
qu'en plus il a des cases de rentrée
voilà il peut revenir à h 2 ou angers 3
et puis qui tape sur ce qu'on sait c'est
donc du coup c'est mobiliser encore un
peu la dalle est là il peut pas jouer un
courant de foudroyage exercice alors sur
fond des filets site pour proposer des
échanges de pièces ouais noble âge et
plusieurs choix je pense alors je peux
peut-être juste protéger avec des
remises des deux si je dis pas de
bêtises
est ce que maintenant si les choses
madame m 15h04 je pense pas mal classés
pareil remplace le jour à la tâte du pi
en silo je peux peut-être essayer de
garder les pièces et je me fous j'ai
cinq peut-être aussi éventuel front des
salles que c'est parce que il a du mal à
jouer un coup comme f6 parce qu'il va
s'affaiblir et la case ou six semaines
donc ça commencerait plus l'europe qui
peut donc cette case est faible le fou
tape dessus c'est un peu con n'a pas
très envie de jouer avec les noirs je
pense à vie parce qu'on pourrait jouer
vous aussi semaine et en cas de prise il
ya cavaliers qui a paru avoir des
frictions
c'est pénible s'est vite s'il vous plaît
peut-être donc pas terrible en fait
finalement donc là simplement aulaqi et
dessin qui prend la case forte puis
surtout c'est à dire ils sont à leur
place son cavalier qui était pas très
bien placé et or là aussi dit ah oui
alors que je vous donnerai option le
voilà et oui on s'est dit il ya une
belle variante là à passer mais si tes
copines c'est à dire que ferait peser
pour fête va dire je n'ai pas trop
regardé d'un programme il faut penser
cet été très compliqué déjà parce que là
je n'ai pas voulu jouer c'est ce que du
coup bah j'ai bien un pion au léman la
dame en dessin qu'elle est très forte et
j'ai perdu beaucoup de cases blanches
qui était je pense très très très très
fort et maintenant ça va être à lui doit
d'ailleurs avec il va pouvoir commencer
à attaquer il va faire tourner ses huit
chats c'est fou oui serré initiative
menacer l'ensemble des pertes ou rêve
des 8
là le four être obligé de revenir par
exemple en g3 mais la suite il peut même
tenté de récupérer
peut être qu'il peut oui effectivement
probable des huit peu comme houphouët si
le plein de coups c'était jouable par la
maison peut-être mais en fait j'ai pas
du tout t'as pas envisager une offre web
parce que je me suis dit si je lui donne
cette position là dessus je verrai ça va
être assez l'osella il va s'amuser
d'accord on a eu peur plus de sa
capacité à tirer parti de l'initiative
que j'ai préféré garder la pression et à
matériel égal plutôt qu'un pion de plus
c'est une position sans trop perfectible
accorde donc je préfère garder
l'initiative
voila voila c'est à noter sabre un bon
réflexe apparemment puisque ça tu as
réussi donc
truc de rentrer dans une gaine de pions
avec
des complications en réalisant que voilà
je rêve ces problèmes parce que ces
pièces ont un petit peu de mal à bouger
et on va [ __ ] en dessin du coup la
dame prendre une bonne place celle là
c'est la casse des huit pour une tour et
c'est donc ça c'est ça aussi de
boycotter pour lui si je fais fou prend
des 5 alors là ils jouent faux g6 alors
ce pas c'est pas facile déjà donné
peut-être pour tenter g7 alors atteint y
avait des trucs tactique parce que en
fait à tout nouveau dans cet état là
c'est pas là donc la foulée suivra un
coup de retrait cir est le foot en l'air
aussi des oeufs
il ya des formes peut y avoir des fous
prend des 5 et d'un prend et tous vos
seins double attaque boulahia pour
l'artois et le caméléon c6 qui contrôle
la case mais ça existe
là après tour c'est un qui va attaquer
un peu ce cas mais ça peut être un thème
puisqu'il va bouger et il peut y avoir
après des double attaque
donc ils préfèrent par exemple un coup
qui pourrait être tentant pour les voir
qui va pas du tout son cavalier à 5 pour
chasser mon fou alors par exemple ça va
pas du tout ça parce que ça paierait le
piège que nokia va laisser six protéines
ne protège plus fous au 7 mai c'est
parce que ses os et benoît un coût pour
les réveiller alors voilà donc ici il ya
cinq là il reprend des saints qui est
fou s'était perdu et voilà et la tour 1
à 2,7
du coup il a du mal à se libérer donc il
faut et donc il n'y a pas trop de coups
fils pouvait s'y attendre et c'est de
protéger ses pièces coin déjà dans cet
avis les pieds mais il voulait aussi
l'idée principale était de fauche son
jeu il est là il l'a c'est peut-être
changer d'univers de pièces mais surtout
ça met un peu la pression sur le sénat
peut être mais là tu joues à 3 oui
c'était pas là c'est un des coups les
plus durs de la partie c'est pas évident
ce qui fait qu'il ya beaucoup naturel
c'est de jouer tour c'est ma première
idée oui et j'avais peur très peur
j'avais peur d'un cavalier en d4 je sais
pas lequel on va dire le d5
oui ça peut être un des cinq il ya la
case d3 qui est un petit peu faible et
oui parce qu'il peut menacer fou prend
une faufilade le carrier bien
naturellement détroit
j'avais un peu peur de ça j'ai encore je
pouvais me permettre de jouer ce coup là
d'accord donc après s'être amélioré sa
position
du coup je me suis permis aux messins
qui s'est passé pas facile parce que je
le laisse jouer c'est un peu dans
l'étude y donnent un coup de jeune à
zéro ce qu'il a fait l'effet fourrage
cinq salles et aux femmes peut aussi
donc voila et la fois je sais mais sur
celle beaucoup plus mollement il menace
fou prend et si tu en prends mes sujets
près de 4 il ya des fois
et puis à tous qui soit apparemment
ainsi parce qu'il ya le feu lié aux
cavaliers en l'air quand il fait font
preuve trois dames preuve 3 je vais
attaquer deux fois le cavalier en d5
aussi ah oui la coupe du coup donc le
tour c'est un tour ça ça protège de
cavale et ce avec maintenant 3 3 ne
marche plus donc on peut regarder en
déranger trois grandes vagues la dame
d'après en éclats et le cavalier des
siens qui est attaquée alors qu'elle
prend des quatre ici car il prend des
cadavres ont des 5 pascal adam prend des
scènes est bon pour la tour serre
protège de caliance et 5 cl échange les
dames le ksc 5
issifou prend mais simplement de tout
reprendre et la dame continue de
protéger le fou web ya aussi ce à quoi
c'est mercredi seulement il n'y a pas de
risque donc à quoi sert pro tour frei
n'ont pas d'âme prend donc tour c'est un
élaphe fouet le 6 mai puis tour serge
meresse cosic elle à lesperon 17 éval
ajournement de la pression et d'ailleurs
c'est le moment en n'ayant pas ce qu'il
a il vous faut et fils est atteint sur
la il est plus qu'un doit de faire quoi
et comment ça pas mal de pression parce
que là le oui le pion des quatre est
attaquée mais mais mais il ya la combine
qui suit qui est une jolie combiné mais
qui était en l'air depuis longtemps mais
celui que tu as pu réussi avait-on
carillon 6 également et la boum il ya
déjà coup de tonnerre dans un ciel
serein
c'est ce qu'on dit oui donc tout reprend
évidemment
non processus donc j'ai gagné a plus en
plus j'ai lineker c6 qui mettait une
pression désagréable way est à noter
qu'aussi il fait maintenant fou prend f3
d'avant je ne peux pas prendre des cas
puisque le kayak est là et on voit qu'à
3 et utile à noter aussi que sur faut
prendre des mois la madame protège
toujours le front heureusement j'ai eu
pas mal de chance soit actif comme ça ça
se dessine c'est de la chance neufbox et
ça se goupille bien que ce mec-là se
protègent se protègent bien grimés
d'accord donc ici d'amd 7 voilà donc là
maintenant leïla tacle à tout mais ça
veut dire qu'il a admis la perte du pur
ans parce que je n'ai pas grand-chose à
tour ces scènes pénibles parce que là il
a des pièces en l'air ce sur la 5eme
roger et oui ça c'est embêtant
donc là il a protégé cloclo se protège
avec ses 6
mais évidemment ça affaiblit attention
là c'est plus facile pour les noms et la
superbe voix 4 à câble dock attaque
l'option c6 donc là il obligé de faire
tourner des six alors ça va sata que le
pion saisie mais en plus ça enlève le
fou voilà la de la taille de la tour
donc on sait jamais donc ça libère adams
ça me donnerait la possibilité de jouer
au bk peut-être plus tard ce qui je veux
ce procès fait à enlever aux lampions
b2en de l'attak de la tour ça menaces ou
processes gagne uqam est donc là il
apporte à l objet de turbo 6 pour
protéger la jeune tour suite à un
problème sur la dernière rangée et à le
problème voilà c'est à dire qu'on a le
fameux mat du couloir est possible ici
et là tu vas faire une commision finale
serment il ya déjà il est mal la
pression blanche est très fort les
pièces blanches ont très bien placé puis
en tant qu il ya un an de plus avec une
les noirs en rien ils ont bien réussi a
finalement apprendre ils ont je sais pas
ce qu'ils ont fait mais ça va pas du
tout et la magnifique tranquille où
jean-françois 160-180 au leader delà du
national
quatrième du national l'an dernier battu
cornet tb sélectionneur de l'équipe de
france female aussi est donc beaucoup de
titres j'ai déjà joué autrefois co2 lui
il m'avait mis trois volets voilà c'est
pas le bon moment pour perdre pour
mathieu que c'est quand même le national
mais quand même regarder boom est
abandonnée parce qu'il va perdre alors
pourquoi attendre alors déjà at on est
obligé de reprendre le foot parce que
sinon ils travaillent et sont prêts à
tout même à la sauce elle se sert donc
ils obligés de prendre
voilà il a hélas tu reprends des
seringues et un des leviers la dame elle
a regardé on peut pas prendre la tour
parce qu'il ya mat du couloir avec trois
buts
oui et donc si la dame par contre sans
d'alger pendant ces huit pour éviter le
mât du couloir et il faut il ya aussi sa
catastrophe
mais s'il joue il y avait foule 3,3
aussi l'anglais n'en reviens pas parce
que je veux dire tu gagnes en 23 courses
et les miniatures en ciment c'est donc
en tout cas ça tu as super départ on est
d'accord
donc tu as deux points et demi c'est ça
sur quatre avec deux victoires donc ça
te met au dessus de la moyenne et tu
étais dans le thé des rentes tard en
tête du tournoi on peut considérer tu
fais partie des joueurs qui sont bien en
tout cas très bien placé
ouais bon super pouvoir te relâcher un
peu voilé les revenus et sur ce rythme
là j'essaie de palma flammes et demain
ce que je peux faire partie fameux
j'étais un beau tenir
c'était la partie face à un peu plus est
tous les pions il t'a posé le pit a fait
un piège en fait de ce qui t'a laissé
venir
ça a marché la gamme est vraiment
facilement de bien jouer j'étais pas
méfiée quoi finalement fait mon ami m
viège de 8 attendu à ce que j'aimerais
ça me paraissent quand je jouais quand
j'ai prié tous les curieux ça me
paraissait ça me paraissait ce qu'il
fallait faire
j'ai fait c'est que c'est le genre
partie ou si ça s'avère être vraie
décision bien ça s'écroule vite et c'est
ce qui s'est un peu passé quoi alors
qu'ils nous viennent de normandie on est
d'accord
wild donc je suis originaire de quimper
en bretagne
voilà j'ai passé toute ma jeunesse la
balle depuis fin 2009 le travail au club
d'amiens au sérieux comme prof d'échec
d'un prophète préfet animateurs aussi la
prof animateurs lentilles maître
international segouin du second de la
session et là tu fais un bon nationale
donc tu es aussi un très très bon joueur
et avec un super tournoi 2016 et puis
bon ben voilà c'est super d'être un truc
je veux que les super joueur c'est
génial on était content de suite parce
que vraiment voilà de belles parties
même c est que tu as perdu heures
finalement été spectaculaire sans rappel
faut fonder le parti aussi eh bien on te
souhaite bien entendu de continuer sur
cette lancée et puis de faire un bon
nationale en enchaînant des surprises tu
as déjà fait un début de national
surprenant va falloir tenir parce que
chaque partie cd client en face à malabo
après la large et plus précieux de déjà
remporté ce tournoi j'avais peur de tout
perdre au début comme je suis là
la gema largement presque de son poids
derrière adrian qui est numéro 9 mai
j'essaie de me faire plaisir de faire ce
que je peux ben c'est pas mal nous on
est content soulagé dans ce championnat
de france 2007 jean françois joly 2è de
l'accession au dernier qui réussit un
super début de tournoi avec deux
voiliers cette magnifique victoire en
face à mathieu corne est une vraie
surprise une vraie surprise de pour ce
national merci à toi jean françois
mercier
merci de nous avoir suivi sur les
modèles de tv puis je vous donne
rendez-vous pour une prochaine émission
au revoir 3